i think it's still going now
you think so yeah
what is it
that's
[Music]
is
there you go mic drops
this is
ready
um
yes
all the way
says
your lives on your own stations
um
is
so now all we need to do is
make sure
is
[Music]
they can't see this
here
[Music]
oh
[Music]
um
i'll get a good one for you
no what
two minutes
okay
oh
right
back
test now
hey how many tv are in here
what time is your tea time out there
thank you goodbye
yes
oh no that's okay i i
so i think
um
is
okay
oh
yes
oh
[Music]
is
is
in the white house
supposedly
you don't hear me you don't hear me
do you guys hear me
[Music]
um
for some reason they're not here
oh
oh
you can still do it on him he may be the
second or third player
left side
testing one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten testing one two
three four
five six seven eight nine ten
can they hear me are they talking to me
what's up
testing one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten testing one two
three four
um
susan you know better
movies
no one's talking this is
okay
um
so
sounds like a good party
this is
two minute warning
go
take it down one more knot okay
yes
[Music]
well thank you very much and good
afternoon
today i want to provide an update on our
response to the china virus
and what my administration is doing to
get the outbreak
in the sun belt under control seems
largely in sun belt but could be
spreading
my team is also working night and day
with capitol hill to advance
the next economic relief package we're
working very hard on it we're making a
lot of progress i also
uh know that uh both sides want to get
it done
we'll call it phase four i think we're
going to get it done we'll
protect our workers our schools and our
families and protect them very strongly
as one family we mourn every precious
life that's been lost i pledge in
their honor that we will develop a
vaccine
and we will defeat the virus we're doing
very well with
vaccine development and therapeutic
development
but i want to thank our brave doctors
and nurses and front line responders
the job they do is incredible and they
are truly brave
my administration will stop at nothing
to save lives and
shield the vulnerable which is so
important we've learned so much about
this disease
and we know who the vulnerable are and
we are going to indeed shield them
and again the vaccines are coming and
they're coming a lot sooner than anyone
thought possible
by years if you look at the old system
and look at the new system i think by
years
the china virus is a vicious and
dangerous illness but we've learned a
great deal about it
and who it targets we are
in the process of developing
some areas of our country are doing very
well others are doing less well
it will probably unfortunately get worse
before it gets better
something i don't like saying about
things but that's the way it is it's the
way
it's what we have you look over the
world it's all over the world
and it tends to do that the governors
are working very very hard
and we are supporting them 100
everything they
need they get and we are taking good
care we have tremendous supplies and
a great supply chain whether it's
ventilators or
gowns or just about anything they need
so that's a big difference from
inheriting very very empty cupboards
the median age of those who succumb to
the china virus is 78 years old
roughly half of all deaths have been
individuals in nursing homes who are
long-term care
in one study 90 percent of those
hospitalized had
underlying medical conditions whether
it's heart
or diabetes but usually it's
some kind of a condition it seems that
people have that and if they do
it's a problem no question about it
young adults may often have mild or even
no symptoms they won't even know they're
sick
they won't have any idea that they have
a virus they won't have any idea at all
america's youth will act responsibly and
we're asking everybody that
when you are not able to socially
distance wear a mask
get a mask whether you like the mask or
not
they have an impact they'll have an
effect and we need everything we can get
data shows children have the lowest
fatality risk
99.96 of
all virus fatalities are in adults think
of that
so that's much much much less than one
percent
for children young people by
understanding these risk
profiles and learning how to treat the
disease
we've been able to greatly reduce
mortality in the united states
in fact we'll show you a chart and
how well we do compared to the rest of
the world we've
have several treatments already
available that significantly reduce the
severity and
duration of the disease including remdi
severe
which has been very successful in a
widely available
steroid treatment and we have many more
happening and coming out
we've learned best practices for
treatment of the virus
at every stage and have shared these
findings with
medical providers and we've shared them
all over the world
but the relationship with other
countries has been very strong we're all
working together this includes ensuring
all hospitals
are aware of the importance of different
approaches to
oxygen treatment including high flow
oxygen
the importance of steroid treatment for
those on ventilators
and when you're on a ventilator we've
learned a tremendous about the use of
the ventilator
and at the beginning people never had an
experience like this
where we needed so many ventilators so
fast and even the use of the vent
letters but the doctors have become
incredibly and nurses and helpers have
become incredibly good at the use of
a ventilator which is actually a very
complicated procedure
and allocating remdi severe to hospitals
based
on new admissions since it works best
early in hospitalization
and that's something that they've really
started they're using it much earlier
fatalities nationwide have fallen 75
since mid-april it's a great number as
cases and fatalities rise in certain
hard-hit states which you're
looking at right now we're surging
personnel supplies and
therapeutics we again have tremendous
amounts of supplies
we are in very good shape and we can
move them quickly
our case fatality rate has continued to
decline and
is lower than the european union and
almost everywhere else in the world
if you watch american television you
think that the united states was the
only country involved with
and suffering from the china virus
well the world is suffering very badly
but the fact is that many countries
are suffering very very very badly
and they've been suffering from this
virus for a long time
we've done much better than most and
with the fatality rate at a
lower rate than most it's something that
we can talk about
but we're working again with them
because we're helping a lot of
countries that people don't even know
about i get calls all the time asking
for help
especially as it pertains to the
ventilators they need
help with ventilators they have to get
them they're very hard to get
we're making thousands now a month
thousands of ventilators a month it's
been
quite amazing we keep doing the good job
and things will get better and better
we'll be putting up charts
behind me showing different statistics
and different
rates of success and i guess you could
say also
things that we can do better on but
you'll see them
they'll be put up as we go in april the
average age of individuals who tested
positive for the virus was
over 50 years old today the average age
is significantly younger hospital
lengths
of stay are almost half of what they
were in april
so the stays are about half the rate of
cases requiring
hospitalization has been reduced and
mortality among those admitted to the
hospital
is nearly one half of what it was in
april we've learned a lot
we've learned a lot about this disease
how to handle it the doctors have
learned a lot
not only in the use of the ventilators
but in many other
things and things are happening too like
the
rem deserver and other elements steroids
etc
but these trends could change without
our continued and relentless focus
and that's what we have we have a
relentless focus and it's been that way
from the beginning
but we've learned so much as you know in
recent weeks we've seen a
concerning rise in the cases in many
parts of our
south if you look at south southwest and
west
this growth in cases first began to
appear in mid-june
primarily among 18 to 35 year olds
many of whom were asymptomatic we're
also facing the challenge of a
significant spice in virus cases across
the
rest of the western hemisphere including
mexico mexico's
been hit very very very hard as you know
the president the great gentleman was
here two weeks ago and they have really
been hit hard
because we've achieved a nearly
four-fold increase in testing capacity
in two months we're
successfully identifying more
asymptomatic and
mild cases some cases so mild that you
really don't even treat them
some cases with children
where they don't even know that they're
ill
and i guess they're not very ill because
they recover almost immediately per
capita the u.s is
conducting 50 more tests than europe
and we've conducted nearly three times
as many tests as all of the other
countries in the western hemisphere
combined the over 50 million tests
this allows us to isolate those who are
infected
even those without symptoms so we know
exactly where it's going
and when it's going to be there we're
also working to reduce turnaround time
my administration has been aggressively
responding to case growth
in the sun belt and we continue to do so
working very close with all governors
but
right now in particular those governors
we're coordinating
closely with hospitals and governors in
the last three weeks i've
sent senior officials into nine states
to meet with
governors and provide recommendations to
the
various leaders of the state including
hospital administrators etc
my administration currently has zero
unfilled
requests for unfulfilled requests for
equipment or anything else that they
need from the governors no governor
needs anything
right now and we think we'll have it
that way till
the end because frankly we are stocked
up and ready to go wherever we have to
go we've nearly
7 000 national guard and military
medical personnel in texas california
florida
and arizona that's helping us greatly
want to thank them very much the
military has been fantastic
we're closely monitoring hospital
capacity in these states hospitals are
open
for elective surgeries and other
procedures so hospitals are open for
elective surgeries we want americans to
get the medical treatments they need all
of the governors
we've spoken with say they have enough
bed capacity that's a great thing
our initial shutdown was to prevent the
overflow
of our hospitals and to allow us to meet
the demands caused by this global
pandemic
including the ventilators and a
permanent shutdown was
really never an option in terms of what
we're doing right now
this would be completely unsustainable
produce
debilitating economic fallback and lead
to catastrophic
public health consequences there are
consequences to shutdowns and
we've saved potentially millions of
lives by doing the initial
shutdown but now we're very aware of
this disease we understand the disease
to a large
extent nobody's going to maybe ever
fully understand it but we'll end up
with a cure we'll end up with
therapeutics we'll end up with a vaccine
very soon
all three we're instead asking americans
to use
masks socially distance and employ
vigorous hygiene
wash your hands every chance you get
while sheltering
high risk populations we are
imploring young americans to avoid
packed bars and
other crowded indoor gatherings be safe
and be smart
we're surging testing capacity to
identify and isolate cases this includes
a newly approved testing platform
to nursing homes across the south we're
being very very vigilant with respect to
nursing homes because you know all of
the problems that we've had
with so many people so sadly they were
infected
so that all of the staff and residents
can be routinely tested and isolated
to ensure our elderly are even more
strongly protected than anybody else
that's really the
high-risk people the high-risk
wonderful people once this current surge
in cases declines this same testing
platform will enable people to visit
their loved ones after taking a test
which is a big difference
ultimately our goal is not merely to
manage the pandemic but to end it we
want to get rid of it as soon as we can
that is why getting a vaccine remains a
top
priority two vaccine candidates are
entering the final stage of clinical
trials this month
this was achieved in record time it used
to be
years before you were in a position like
we are right now
four other vaccines will enter final
trials in
the following weeks and we're mass
producing all of the top candidates so
that the first approved vaccine will be
available immediately
and logistically we have the military
ready to go we have
great people logistic military people
a wonderful general who's waiting for
the vaccine so they can distribute it in
record time that's what's going to
happen so
our military is all set to go we will
deliver a vaccine
therapeutics whatever it is is necessary
and defeat the virus once and for all
and i'll take a few questions if you'd
like
i will say this i want to thank all of
the staff the white house staff
all of the doctors that we've been
working with so closely and
it's just a lot of very positive things
are happening it's a nasty
horrible disease that should have never
been allowed to escape china but it did
and it infected the world
and the world is suffering but we're
going to get it taken care of
and we're helping lots of other
countries john
mr president first i just want to get a
clarification your press secretary said
today that you
sometimes take more than one test a day
well why is that
and how well i didn't know about more
than one i do ten probably on average a
test
every uh two days three days and i don't
know if any time i've taken two tests in
one day but
i could see that happening so
republicans and democrats on capitol
hill both said they want to see
more money for testing they want to send
billions of dollars to the state so they
can do more testing
and you probably saw mick mulvaney the
other day said that uh his kids it took
him a week to get test results back he
said this is simply
inexcusable given where we are in the
pandemic
do you think we have a problem with
testing in this country right now and
are you in favor of more money for
testing
we've done more testing by far than
anybody some of the tests because it is
massive volume it takes longer
others of the tests as you know are very
quick they're five minutes and 15 minute
tests
and those are frankly the ones that i
prefer but we're doing
massive numbers and the numbers are
coming down and
as we go as an example there are
thousands and thousands of
kits being made right now which give you
a 15 minute and a five minute test
so we'll be able to get those numbers
down those numbers are similar in other
places uh they're also
doing massive numbers numbers like
nobody thought possible
but those numbers will be coming down i
agree i think it's a good thing if we
can do it are you in favor of more money
protection
well they're going to make presentation
to me tonight and tomorrow on that and
again we're leading the world i think
the second country at 12
would be over 50 million tests
second country is india with 12 million
uh then you have 7 million 6 million and
4 million
i think that uh we are doing tremendous
amount of testing but if if
if the doctors and the professionals
feel that
even though we're at a level that nobody
ever dreamt possible that
they would like to do more i'm okay with
it what are your doctors not with you
here today
dr burks well dr burks is right outside
yes please
thank you mr president i've got two
questions for you um number one i just
wanted to know
in november do you want the american
people to judge you
do you want the american people to judge
you on the ballot in november by how do
you handle this pandemic so far
this among other things i think the
american people will
judge us on this but they'll judge us on
the economy that i created and that
already we're creating we're setting
record job numbers as you know
uh i think we're going to have a very
strong year next year i think we're
going to have a very strong third
quarter
a very good fourth quarter but i think
next year is going to be a record year
and i think they're going to judge me of
that i think they're going to judge me
on the tax cutting and the regulation
cutting which
nobody's ever done to the extent that
we've been able to do it on rebuilding
the military
on how we've handled the va on the va we
got veterans choice nobody thought that
would be possible that's been many
decades they've been trying to get
veterans choice
it's called choice where they can go get
a doctor if they have to wait online for
two weeks or five weeks or two days
and frankly that's been a great thing
veterans accountability i think they'll
judge me on that
they'll judge me in all of the things
we've done i don't think
and i think we can say this we surely
and it's never been even challenged in
three and a half years the first three
and a half years the first years of a
presidency i don't think any
administration any president has
accomplished so much as we've
accomplished from energy
to health to so many other things and
then this came in
and uh the the plague i call it the
plague the plague came
in terrible thing should have been
stopped wasn't stopped
it came in we had to shut things down to
save potentially millions of lives we
did that
and now we've started them up and uh i
think we've really started it up very
successfully
thank you you've been saying for months
the virus would simply
disappear and now you're saying that
it's likely to get worse before it gets
better
if it does keep getting worse if
americans keep dying
are you responsible for that well the
virus will disappear
it will disappear i think that i always
like to say as
you know either way when you look at it
the governors are working with me i'm
working with the governor we're working
hand in hand i think we're all
responsible i view it as a team
very good relationships with the
governors very very good relationships
uh i could say i'm fully responsible but
you know one day we had a virus come in
and i closed the borders did a lot of
things that were very good
in fact dr fauci said we saved tens of
thousands of lives when i closed the
border and nobody wanted to do it i
wanted to do it
we closed the border to china we put on
the ban
we didn't want people coming in from
heavily infected china
fairly shortly thereafter i closed the
borders from
europe coming in from europe those were
tremendous moves we would have
if it's one person it's too much but
we're at let's say 140 000
we could have double triple quadruple
that number if we didn't so
we did a lot of things right we did a
lot of things right including with
equipment
so uh it's a shame that it happened it
shouldn't have happened
china should have stopped it
um my first question is we have a very
quick
testing platform here at the white house
yes it's great you get tested you know
very quickly do you think that it would
be easier to reopen
and restart businesses if we could
produce more of those machines we're
trying to do that
great question we're trying very much to
do that so rather than sending your
tests in and you know goes through the
mail one day
comes back another day no matter how
they send them
it's a day and a day so that's two days
already wasted
and then if it spends by the time you
get it back it's three or four days if
they do an efficient job we're trying to
get the testing on site
thank you i like it the best and it's my
follow-up my second question that's a
little bit
different topic but it's one that a lot
of people are talking about um
just lane maxwell is in prison and a lot
of people want to know
if she's going to turn in powerful
people and i know you've talked in the
past about prince andrew
and you've criticized bill clinton's
behavior i'm wondering uh
do you feel that she's going to turn in
powerful men how do you see that working
out
i don't know i haven't really been
following it too much i just wish her
well frankly
i've met her numerous times over the
years especially since i lived in palm
beach and
i guess they lived in palm beach but i
wish her well
whatever it is uh i don't know the
situation with prince andrew
just don't know not aware of it
on unemployment insurance how much below
600 are you willing to go and you said
that the
economy is bouncing back strong so why
do we need to even cut it at all
well the economy is getting stronger and
i think we have a chance to have a very
strong economy especially if
some of the things that i just spoke
about were we want to have people
go back and want to go back to work as
opposed to be sort of forced into a
position where they're making more money
than
they expected to make and the employers
are having a hard time getting them back
to work
so that was a uh
decision that was made i was against
that original decision but they did that
it still worked out well because it gave
people a lifeline a real level and now
we're doing it again
they're thinking about doing 70 of the
amount the amount would be the same but
doing it in a little bit smaller
initial amounts so that people are going
to want to go back to work as opposed to
making so much money
that they really don't have to but we
were very generous
with them i think that uh it's been a
tremendously successful program the
whole thing has been successful if you
look i mean we have
we're in a pandemic and yet we're
producing tremendous number of
jobs that was something that nobody
thought possible okay mr president thank
you very much
yesterday you said that wearing a mask
was an act of patriotism
if that is the case why don't you do it
more frequently well i do actually do it
what i need i mean i carry the mask when
i have to go
i went into walter reed hospital the
other day
i have the mask right here i carry it
and i will use it gladly
no problem with it and i've said that
and i say if you
can use the mask when you can use the
mask
if you're close to each other if you're
in a group i would put it on when i'm in
a group
uh if i'm in an elevator and there are
other people with me including like
security people it's not their fault
they have to be in the elevator i want
to protect them also
i put on a mask uh i will have i have no
problem with the mask
i view it this way anything that
potentially can help
and that certainly can potentially help
is a good thing i have no problem i
carry it
i wear it you saw me wearing it a number
of times and i'll continue please
thank you thank you go ahead are you
sending mixed messages though yesterday
you tweeted out an image wearing a mask
and then last evening we saw you not
wearing a mask at your hotel
well i don't know uh the hotel i was
pretty far away from people but
i would say this uh i've explained it i
think very
well uh if you're close together i would
put on the
mask and if you're not i would say that
if you're
for instance i'll see like here you've
been all tested i've been tested
often times i'll be with people that are
fully tested i've been tested
in theory you don't need the mask i'm
getting used to the mask
and the reason is think about patriotism
maybe it is
it helps it helps now we have experts
that have said in the recent past that
masks
aren't necessarily good to wear you know
that but now they've changed their mind
if they change their mind that's good
enough for me so i wear it when
appropriate please
thank you sir um a lot of americans
though may be surprised
at your change of tone over all of this
some more perhaps realistic tone someone
looking at it that way
the sudden embrace of masks social
distancing
the uh well i've always agreed with that
i mean i've never fought
either one but certainly social
distancing i want to
it's that's common sense six feet from
me is common sense i'd like to say maybe
make it a little bit further
the idea that things will get worse
perhaps before they get better here
and perhaps the realization that this
resurgence
if you will is for real when you used to
talk about it in terms of little fires
being put out
here and there we have them no we have
embers and fires and we have big fires
and
unfortunately now florida is uh in a
little tough
uh or in a big tough position uh you
have a great governor there you have a
great governor in texas you have
people that are very very skilled people
and i think they're going to handle it
very well
uh their hospital capacities are holding
up but texas is a big state and it's
very well run and so is florida and
i think they'll do a very good job
changing your tone though
ask you about the issue of vaccines
which you already mentioned um
yesterday a study by a chinese company
showed some promising results for its
coronavirus vaccine candidate
if china were first in developing the
vaccine or even if it were
would the administration be willing to
work with china to bring a successful
chinese vaccine to the u.s
yeah we're willing to work with anybody
that's going to get us a good result
we're very close to the vaccine i think
we're going to have some very good
results we're already in testing nobody
thought that would be possible under the
old system would be a year to two years
before you could even think about
using the word testing so i think we've
had a lot of
and the reason we're testing they've had
good results so now we have to see in
the testing also for safety
just have to make sure it's safe and i
think you're going to see
something over the next fairly short
period of time maybe very short period
of time having to do with therapeutics
and vaccines
that are very good so we'll be doing
these quite often
we're going to keep you abreast of this
and we'll also talk about some of the
other topics like our economy which is
doing well the stock market had another
good day i think they have a good day
because they see
a lot of positive things happening on
this front too thank you very much thank
you
[Applause]
testing one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten